pressez-vous carole grimaud potter
bonjour professeur en géopolitique de la
russie à l'université de montpellier
fondatrice du think tank créé center for
law and eastern europe research merci
d'être d'être à nos côtés vous
intervenez en direct de genève une
première question que l'on se pose
forcément c est ce que les russes
sont en train ou non de suivre aussi
cette séquence et images qui sont en
train de faire le tour du monde et une
réaction du kremlin le kremlin a jugé il
ya quelques instants futiles les
livraisons d'armes occidental à à
l'ukraine
oui effectivement ça vient de sortir là
il ya quelques minutes
alors il regarde bien sûr tout cela
attentivement ne s'attendent pas à des
annonces qui pourraient marquer un
tournant de toute façon dans cette dans
cette guerre et trouve effectivement le
mot futile a été utilisé il utile
finalement toutes ces visites qui se
sont succédé à kate ne vois pas
l'utilité ni l'utilité ni finalement un
indice générant un tournant majeur dans
leurs objectifs et continue donc cette
guerre notamment dans le combat sur
toute la ligne de contact une guerre
féroce et qui elle prévoit que de très
nombreuses pertes du côté ukrainien du
côté russe aussi est-ce qu'on peut
s'imaginer que ce genre de déplacement
fortement symbolique 1 3 dirigeants des
pays fondateurs de l'union européenne en
train de s'entretenir là un moment où
l'on se parle avec le président
ukrainien volodimir zelensky dans son
palais alors que le pays est toujours en
état en état de guerre et bien cette
nature à agacer moscou agacé vladimir
poutine écoutez je ne pense pas je ne
pense pas que cela la casse au plus haut
point je pense que le plus important ce
sont les livraisons d'armes c'est à dire
l'aide qui va être décidé et qui a été
décidé hier avec 7,7 cette aide
américaine
très importante qui va d'une eau de
nouveau accordé donc l ukraine sont ces
l'aide militaire et l'adhésion l'union
européenne je crois que ça est à ce
point là est très important pour les
russes est-ce que l'huile l'ukraine va
obtenir ce statut de candidat à
l'adhésion à l'union européenne ou pas
là que deux choses importantes après les
déclarations je parle des présidents
français allemand italien ne représente
pas peut-être une source finalement de
d'intérêt supplémentaire pour pour la
russie aujourd'hui
évoquer l'aide l'aide militaire pour
l'ukraine 1 milliard de dollars d aides
supplémentaires annoncés hier par par
joe biden est probablement nouvelles
annonces prochainement les européens
devraient devraient aussi suivre en tout
cas et devrait confirmer cesser ses
livraisons en de façon un peu plus
concrète ça ça pourrait changer la donne
réellement demain oui c'est à dire que
7,7 cette aide
s'était militaire qui va augmenter
puisque c'est effectivement la demande
du secrétaire général de l'otan qu'il a
il exprimé hier donc une aide qui doit
augmenter qui doit être de plus en forte
on doit soutenir continuer à soutenir
l'ukraine parce que la réalisation cost
finalement cette guerre va être longue
ouvre finalement une porte sur sur notre
nature et c'est une guerre d'usure et
les les pays alliés qui ont fourni déjà
m militaire à l'ukraine doit continuer à
le faire et doivent continuer à le faire
encore plus alors cela porte sur les
armes lourdes cela porte les munitions
surtout ce que les ukrainiens réclame et
sur les l'armement de longue portée nous
savons que les états unis ont refusé
donc d'accorder cette aide particulière
de peur que l'ukraine pourrait pourrait
atteindre le territoire russe donc cette
cette acquisition d'armes à longue
portée et tout à fait décisive pour les
ukrainiens ils le réclament et sans cela
d utiles ils ne pourraient ne faut kong
a regagné la guerre dans l'impasse
ccn militaires sont effectivement
crucial aujourd'hui à entendre les
déclarations françaises notamment il ya
cette source diplomatique qui confiait
ce matin nous sommes pour une victoire
intégrale avec le rétablissement de
l'intégrité territoriale les mots ont
leur importance sur tous les territoires
conquis par les russes y compris la
crimée à entendre ces propos sont aussi
des manuels macron qui voit déjà au delà
de cette guerre ans quand la guerre sera
terminé quand l'ukraine l'aura emporté
on a le sentiment m'a finalement que les
ukrainiens vont remporter ce conflit est
que les russes ont tout à y perdre
les russes ont tout à y perdre déjà a
perdu beaucoup les ukrainiens bien sûr
aussi les deux pays ont tout à perdre de
toute façon ensuite cette cette victoire
quelques elle et elle est réellement la
victoire du côté même les uc du côté
ukrainien la victoire était la
reconquête de tous les territoires
également occupé également la crimée on
sait que dernièrement il ya quelques
semaines
et a dit que cette reconquête totale
serait est impossible et causerait de
trop lourdes pertes à l'armée
ukrainienne au peuple ukrainien donc les
les les paroles et les [__] les paroles
dans un big air et pense que représente
uniquement une posture c'est ça que vous
êtes en train de dire pardon c'est
uniquement une posture c'est à dire que
les huiles les parents de change au jour
le jour je dirais par rapport à cela
alors il est vrai qu'il faut tenir dans
la durée
maintenant la victoire quelle est elle
nous savons que du côté européen la
victoire ukrainienne pour certains pays
passerait par une une acceptation de
perte de territoire ce qui est tout à
fait inacceptables pour l'ukraine bien
entendu d'autres veulent aller jusqu'au
bout repousser la russie dont seulement
repoussé la russie mais et reconquérir
tous les cas pas cela était possible
nous ne savons pas nous voyons
aujourd'hui que dans le temps de base la
russie fait
de faibles a connu de faibles avancées
le cren n'apparaît au kerry ont conquis
les territoires pris part par la russie
noyant c'est un bon qui s'enlise et nous
voyons aussi que dans le sud de
l'ukraine
s'opère aujourd'hui une russification
qui va être remercié
demain merci beaucoup carole bimoteur
merci à vous vous étiez notre amédée du
jour est plus que vous